johnny means happy john means day well
i'll tell you what he has gotten it
going again as of late making his 25th
appearance of the year 3.2 era dulles
was hitless yesterday over four with a
couple of strike counts means waste
little time in his 2-1 pitch a curveball
and that one on the ground in the hole
short cut off by the third baseman
gutierrez but he can't get it to first
in time
[Applause]
painted it strike three he k's low
give us an opportunity to take a look at
the numbers for dane dunning 25 games on
the season this will be his 24th start
the two relief appearances that he had
he took those after he came off the
covet il
hayes will send this one to third base
culberson right there for it and it
completes a quick
scoreless bottom of the first only nine
pitches needed for dane dunning we go to
the second 0-0 the abanias trevino and
calhoun in this inning i want to be able
to turn it up a notch or two
well means slowed it down to notch your
two right there and picks up his first
strikeout off the changeup trevino he
went three for three yesterday two
singles and then a home run his first
home run since june 21st
breaking ball and this one lined up the
middle he's four for his last four
just remember when jonah heim was down
for a little while jose trevino got that
nice run of consistent playing time
went right back to it
strike three so john means strikes out
this side in the second inning and again
it comes off the chain shot now john
means first he gets in bonies he was the
third one in the second inning john
means to leyote tavares the full count
pitch
wave and a miss
and a change up and down goes to varys
for means fifth strikeout well here it
comes again 3-2
soft contact to the left side gutierrez
the spin the throw got him as you know
looked at the scout report
the scouts were saying well you know
it's it's average defense it's it's okay
defense it's average big league well he
has been well above average defensively
top four middle of the order do up for
texas swing and a miss fastball and
means blows it by garcia one down
in the top of the fourth here comes low
and this one is the opposite way on the
ground and through and low has a base
hit and here's andy abunas who struck
out in the second
andy hits this ball pretty well out to
left field will it stay fair it is gone
andy abanez with a two run shot
and the rangers get on the board first
this afternoon
you just mentioned all of those times
that
means has gotten behind these rangers
hitters and you feel like somebody was
going to cash it in sooner or later and
that guy ended up being andy ibanez he's
a good look at the change-up grip and
that just stayed right in the middle
played elevated that's not what he
wanted to do with that pitch it was a
pretty unusual looking grip yeah that
was kind of his two middle fingers on
that changeup middle and ring finger the
haze to lead things off here against
dunning it's all about making a quality
pitch if you make a quality pitch down
in the zone and stay out of the middle
part of play i think your results are
going to be good no matter what area you
pitch in
not a lot of quality pitches there is
hazel earn a five-pitch walk now here's
santander it has more of a flatter swing
maybe you can go two-seamer there's a
deep fly ball to right field and it's
out of here
into the front row anthony santander
ties this up at two it ends in all for
13 for santander and we are level
now that's what i'm talking about 99 off
the bat 383 feet and almost a line drive
as it got out to right center field
santander's 18th long ball of the year
his 50th rbi and that is a sight for
sore eyes there see that's a two-seam
fastball but you see the location of it
so it's not about because while he threw
a two-seamer he ran into it no he ran
into it because it was a better pitch
really tavares first step
now the payoff
and this one lined into left field
that's a base hit leyote
is a board
amines goes to the well one too many
times last at bat he ended up striking
out leo tavares with a 3-2 change-up
this time around he goes with a 3-2
change-up again
fastball this one on the ground second
pace and whoops nobody home for the
double play pat valencia
that was kind of a no-look flip and i'm
not sure
if he's at fault i mean i guess he's got
to be somewhat at fault but where was
richie martin
i think martin just was sleeping he
didn't
[Music]
what in the world
i don't think he oh my gosh he should be
there look where he is oh he didn't see
the ball oh he did not see it off the
bat you could see his reaction right
away see his hands go up dulles garcia
the battery has an infield hit and a
strike yet
i don't know i have no idea who's gonna
win that's a fair ball that'll get home
at least one run
tavares is in conner falefa will stop at
third on the garcia double well this
will certainly help the cause here he
goes out in front of this pitch and a
nice hard ground ball down the left
field line hooks it good attempt there
by gutierrez but he is a little bit late
means puts him away on the curve ball
yeah and he put him away on the best
breaking ball he's thrown all day long
to a really good hitter
leone tavares will be first up for texas
in the seventh is the difference as he
rips this one right by the pitcher and
past the bag at second and out into
center field so a leadoff single here in
the seventh for leote he's now two for
three in the ball game rangers looking
to add to their one run advantage and
they hope he'll be able to get on base
regularly he takes off pitches up and
out go to second nowhere near in time
kiner falefa 0 for three from handhold
and that ball's hit hard out into left
field that drops in base hit tavares
will be waved around third here comes a
throw to the plate not in time
one strike pitch to him and he taps this
one over the mound
jones bobbles it
he whipped it he just flat missed it
i bet nobody got close to that this year
that's in the dirt ball four
and the pitch to
three-two pitch and this one lined out
into right field that's a base hit and
it gets past santander to the wall
it'll get a run to the plate
that'll get two runs to the plate and
heading to third is calhoun he's in
there with a two-run triple fastball on
the short seams and you know willie has
done this now a couple of times today
going outside and hooking a ball looking
like just a kind of a line drive base
hit but watch santander he was not
expecting that ball to skip the way that
it did so a four run ranger lead and
they have out hit the orioles 11-2
payoff pitch
and that ball down the left-field line
that'll be extra bases for culberson
another run is in culberson with the rbi
double
and it's seven to two a look at mancini
severino and valencia here in the bottom
half of the ninth inning
and ceni hits it through the left side
so trey's got himself a off single
except severino who's gotten two walks
that is belted out to left it is down
the line it is gone
pedro savarino with a two run homer as
mancini reaches and severino brings them
around to make it a three-run game joe
barlow has come on the pitch this will
be his 29th game of the season with the
rangers 26 and two-thirds innings two
home runs allowed a sparkling 124
batting average against 2-2 pitch
and mckenna strikes out swinging this
one is over barlow gets the save
rangers split the series
you